如果对方最终的带孩子的模式是爸爸也不管，交给爷爷奶奶放到农村，那我建议你就是拼了命也得争孩子的抚养权，他想来闹，我又没有，我又没有偷人，我又没有违法，我又没有犯罪，我不怕你闹啊，你随便闹啊，我们是一九年通过一个朋友的聚会认识啊，但是我们当时都是在28左右嘛，家里都催婚催的比较急，那他家人也是他家催的比较急的时候，我们一月份认识，然后他就跟他家人介绍了我说他有对象干嘛了，然后我们就回去见了父母，见了父母之后呢，父母他可能也至于想让他早点结婚，本来我也有打算买房的嘛，那父后呢，那你们就去看房吧，然后到我们县城看了一套房子，103万，当时我们首付先付了17万多，后面的话用我母亲的名字开发商贷了一年免利息的，就第二年还另外一半15万的这个首付款，但是当后面看完房，友培去跟他爸爸说说，他爸就说他可以支持，怎么，因为之前在次结婚之前，他跟他姐姐就他爸爸为了结婚嘛，因为以前他谈了一个女朋友，他要求在外面买房，然后因为这个事情没有谈妥，他就分手了，他爸就逼着他分手了，他就拿了25万左右跟他姐姐合资在广州买了套房子，写在他个人名下，他就说那你们要结婚的话，到时候叫他跟他姐姐说，把那广州房子给他姐姐那个钱退出来，挪到我们这边过来用于我们买。
方的意思，当时他们写我一个人名字，我们还没领证的写我一个名字，当时他的理由是说如果写他的名字会有二套首付，这个费用会更高嘛。其实当时他们隐瞒了一个，就是他在婚前有喜欢网贷的这一个习惯，当时他查了征信，让我发现这个事儿，后面我就说他写一写了，后面我们直到2020年8月领的证，然后2020年7月我已经怀孕了，当时我家人的想法就说没有跟他们太要彩礼，就说那你们家也拿了钱来买房啊什么之类的，就心想着就随便你们忙意思一下就好了。然后他爸当时就说，那我们不摆酒席，就是说那我们再额外补5万块钱给你们去，先自别人们缓解房贷压力嘛，然后我们就说可以等真正要结婚的前两天呢，他爸就没有履行这个承诺，就只给了2万块钱彩礼现金，因为这个事情我就问他，我说那你们家当时不是这样说，怎么突然变卦了，我说既然我们家人们跟你们要，但是话已经说出来了，肯定在我们那边，也不可能是2万的彩礼嘛，对不对？或者是你就算不想给，那我们也要提前，这个事情要告知我们嘛，但是你不红包，要结婚那一天你再这样子毅然决然去做，所以我就感觉很不好，我家人也很开心，我要做成，要么这婚不结，我妈就劝我，就说不要因为这几万块钱，那我爸心里不开心，就算他给你的，到时候你们去了也不开心，我就被他们说服了，那就留下了，就那时候也有怀孕一个月，我心想那也就算了，因为这个事情过。
我先说一下我公公，她是一个非常强势的人，她是一个校长，退休了，我婆婆是个老师，她是我婆婆嫁给他几十年，连她工资多少都不知道，就全全工资卡都在我公公那里，家里要吃什么用什么都是由我公公去支出，实在你没办法，要随点年轻可能他会给个五百一千，这样子就要掌控力非常强，甚至家里吃什么他都要决定，他喜欢吃猪肉了，人家觉得如果哪怕我们买一个海鲜，逢年过节回来，他都会觉得这个东西好像不值得的那种感觉，就是不白脸色。还有一个就是在她家里，她的三姐妹，一个哥一个姐，他们家的男士是实时不张家，就实是一点东西都不会干，全部之前都是跟妈妈干，后面她有了嫂子跟嫂子干，嫂子干完我去，都是我干，那我们就新管，有时候呢，逢年过节回家，我们在外面工作嘛，没有去住，然后我们回去过年不招待人，基本上都是我跟他嫂子干活，酒饭之类的，那他妈妈也很辛苦，做了很多东西，我们心想的那回去能帮忙就帮忙做。但是我公公还是会挑事，比如说我第一秒有去炒菜，他会觉得你炒的太上火了，这不好那不好就挑。那我今早就跟他嫂子说，那嫂子你来家里比较久，比较时道他们符合胃口，那你去转啥，我去帮你打下手，我来洗碗什么之类的，但是我公公还是依然不满意，到了年初一吃中午饭，他都要挑刺我的课，说我干的少了什么的，但是我忍了，我嫂子说年初一也不想那么难堪，在家里吃饭就吵架，后面我也没说什么，但是现在他是想闹分开那。
公开呢，我们谈过，还有一个中介还发现一件事情，在二二年的时候帮我小孩，本来生孩子也是他们催的，现在他们就说你们生了我帮你带，帮我帮我生了之后吧，我在外面工作嘛，他就说帮我出来带20天，他就不愿意了，他说我要回家不舒服，各种不舒服，然后我说那你回去了，就让我妈忙来帮忙了一个月，那我妈妈家里有孙子，然后就没办法，我就说那要么请个保姆，但是我既然从我怀孕到生孩子一年半的时间，我老公他既然骗我，他都没有去上班，就是每天像个上班人一样，早上8点出去，晚上9点回来，实际上他没有去上班，这个事情是怎么爆发的呢？是在二二年的时候，他既然爆发出来，他扛不住了，有网贷了，到信用卡报网贷应该有30来万吧，然后我就问他你这些钱哪里去了，就说我因为那生活，因为当时的分工是这样的，他负责房贷跟房租，我负责生活费跟小孩部分的是我负责这样的分工，他可能就没有去工作这一年半，我说那你到底去干嘛？他就说他每天出去半学回来这无人一样的，然后他可能就摆到了二二年，我婆婆他们不愿意带孩子的，他就说那我来带吧，二一年就得说我来带吧啊，我说那不行，我说你你说带男，我甚在在家里读个大学，你说在家带孩子也就不好嘛。我说那要么请个保姆，我说我们都是双休，他这样子我能辛苦一下，我为女儿带嘛，白天让保姆看一下，我说也是五六千块钱，总比你在家好，不然到时候说出去或者你觉得委屈，你在家带孩子也不合适。他就。
不会不会的，我就来过渡一下，那我说那你不能怨我，他说好，那就他坏了，他带到了22年年初，我说这样子不行，你还是要出去工作，孩子想办法，后面我就叫我亲姐姐，因为他是看店的，我说我亲姐姐帮我带，我爷爷给4000块钱给他，然后我帮我贷了半年吧，我说那这样子，他说工作不好找什么的，我说那行，我本来也要婚前的车，二三十万，我带到他家去，他家钱有贷款，那时候已经付了20万了，他不愿意要，他爸说车是消耗品，不愿意要好，那我没要，没要我就把他给卖了，因为20多万车去开滴滴是不划算的，我把他卖了，他当时跟我哥哥也出了点钱，我自己手上能拿到8万块，我就给他首付了，一样便宜一点的车十几万，结果付了4万首付给他，我说那你如果工作实在不好找，跑跑滴滴什么的啊，总会有收入嘛，是吧，孩子可能也比较自由，比如说小孩干嘛的，我们也能够看得到，或者是说平时周末去看孩子，各方面也比较好调节嘛，好了就车买给他，他既然每天又装模作样的出去，还是没有跑，偶尔聊天，我说你跑的怎么样啊，跑怎么问他，他都很打复衍，但是我就越觉得越不对劲，我去看了一下我车的公里数，他很害怕，我朋友车我基本上不开，这的工作离家很近，都是不用打车的，然后后面我就看我朋友家的，我就咨询了一下，看到别人的滴滴跑的公里数跟我家的那个公里数差太远了，我就觉得不对劲，后面我让他酝酿，他给我看流水，他不肯不肯，后面他就爆发出他那个二二年中旬的时候，他爆发出他欠了多少钱。
事情我就很崩溃，他拿不出证据，我后面他姐姐通过关系打了他征信，我看了他从2016年就开始有网上借款的这种行为，那就是专门贷。大学的时候我问他家人，他姐姐说他当公时跟他买那套房的时候，他们也才知道他给网贷了几万块钱没还，然后贷款贷不了，后面他家人帮他还掉了这几万块钱，然后才审批的资格，后面我也没有说既然有孩子了，也没有说指责过于什么，那我说那这样子我跟他父母他买，那时候就一直逼着我想把房子卖了，你知道吗？就他帮他还这个债，但是我觉得日子要过，你总不能就靠这点房子，你那时候房贷也跌了，卖也可能只卖出一个首付来，对不对，那你卖掉之后如果什么都没有了，我跟着你判啥呢？我的意思是我给你条件是你出去赚钱，我一分钱都不要，你的孩子什么我来养，比如说一年存5万，我们每年到了年底再给你几万块钱，相当于一年大概能还掉10万块，你二三十万两年多也能还掉了，我就这个意思，那他本来答应的好好的，但是没有做到，但他爸妈估计家人比我更了解他，知道他做不到，他爸还要求我每个月要给他打钱，比如说叫他儿子每个月给他存3000，我每个月至少给打俩钱到我姑娘那里去，我不同意，我说我要看到他年底，比如说你存了5万，我可以拿3万几万给你一起去还，然后我公公因为这个事情也觉得我很不满意，他们就很穷，就是说在很没钱，其实我公公他们退休工资一个月1万多，我其实我也没指望他们，只是我就觉得日子要过，你们总要去说一下这个。
我来问你啊，现在你老公总共还欠多少钱，我不清楚，应该很多都话都就是摆烂了不管了，估计也要三四十万吧，你名下那套房，你婆家总共出了多少钱，应该不到30吧，25左右，那你现在想要问我的问题是什么？他现在去起诉了，要求我返回他那些首付的费用，谁去起诉的，我老公因为他想分开，他想分开，他想跟你分开，然后他要求你还那30万给他是吧？对对，现在你要面临的问题是，第一这个房子买在你名下，第二是在结婚之后买的是吗？离婚之前，第三这个30万当时是公公婆婆转账吗？还是你老公给你转账，他不是一次性转的，就是第一次，我老公可能转的十来万也不是他父母转的，他是通过他姐姐之前叫他姐姐退了一些钱过来，可能他姐姐给他，他转给我是你老公转给你的哈，对好，总共你老公婚前给你转了差不多30万来买这个房产，然后他现在的诉求是要求你退他30万是吧，对，然后他还要要求退我们共同房贷的部分，他说共同房贷他还了30个月，我还了20个月，实际上他没有还那么久是吧，实际上我们总共供了50期，他还了31了27，他要求要分这个还房贷的这个钱，但是现在房子我已经卖掉了，我在二三年的时候我已经卖了。
把公的钱全亏了，只卖到手可能也就是32万，亏了多少钱，公的全亏了就是到手大概32万，就剩下一个首付，那你得告诉我亏了多少钱，亏了22万，那现在你老公的要求是第一还30万的首付款，第二这22万他要分11万是吧？嗯，然后还有我给他买的车，我拿我跟钱的车钱给他买一辆，然后他有10万块钱，只贷了10万嘛，他就故意不还款，车现在他在用，我说那你不好好开，他就卖掉吧，然后底下他不愿意，他故意不还，就现在他还说这个共同债务有10万也要我承担50%，那个车也是在你名下是吧，在他的名下他不是贷不了款吗？怎么后来他又能贷，他贷当时是这样的，因为我买的车不多钱，跟他去买了14万，我给了他4万首付，贷了10万，当时4S店员我不知道他是没有把这辆车去做抵押，先给他办了一张信用卡的模式，你知道吧，这个绿本我看过，完全没有做过抵押，所以因为我当时他不还款，我就很纳闷，那不还款我就想正好啊，让人家把车给拉走嘛，反正我也没用到，是不是我来给你讲一下啊，在法律上他想让你退婚前给的那30万是很难的，为什么呢？因为婚前他转给你的大概率下会被认定为是以结婚为目的的赠与，就是彩礼钱，然后呢，你跟他又结了婚，也生了小孩，所以他婚。
之前那30万想让你退是很有难度的，基本上是很难退的回去的，但是他要求的是婚后还贷款这一部分，要求他要你退，他是有这个法律依据在的，就是婚后还贷款这一部分，比如说总共还了22万，他要求你给11万，这个在法律上有一定的支撑，但是你要拿出证据证明这个房子是跌价了，那么他也应该承担一部分损失，比如说这个房子跌掉了50%，那么他这11万也就跌掉了50%，你要这样去主张，那么法官有可能采信你的这个主张，因为大家都是夫妻嘛，如果房子涨价了，大家一起享受这个涨价带来的利益，那房子跌价了，我们作为夫妻也要一起来承担这个跌价带来的风险，这个是公平的。至于说他买的那个车子，因为他在他名下嘛，他不还那随他咯，那他是属于共同债务嘛，因为这个车子是婚后你花钱给他买的是吧，是属于婚后的，然后这个车子呢，他又用来跑滴滴，他用来跑滴滴相当于是他的一个经营行为，那么他这个贷款是有可能被认定为是妻共同的债务的，那么这个车子也是夫妻共同的财产，什么意思呢？就看这个车子现在值多少钱，如果这个车子还值8万块钱，那我不要了呀，我这8万块钱我不分啊，我这4万块钱我不要了。
啊，就这意思，你要想让我承担5万块钱的贷款，那我这是不是还得分4万块钱给我，但是我这4万块钱我不要了，我也不想承担这个贷款了，这个也是能说的明白的，那还有一个问题，现在他除了这诉求还有一个诉求，他诉状里面写说我从小孩出生到现在，因为现在小孩4岁半了，他说我从来没有带过孩子，都是由他跟他父母带，我没有履行义务，说我离家出走了，说希望法院怕，但是就是不符合事实了嘛，对吧，本来过年的时候跟他谈了一轮，我说好聚好散嘛，他就是属于那一种很爱面子的，其实他对孩子没有那么好，但是他想要面，我说想，那你要抚养权，那OK，过年我好好谈，我说我给你，因为我们两家离得不远，我说你只要不阻止我看孩子抚养费我该给的我也给大家，为了孩子好对不对？他本来同意了，但是过年没时跟他反悔，但现在他说孩子抚养权他的诉求要给他，我每个月还支付1500块钱抚养费，因为这个事情本来我不知道，他起诉了是刚收到，后面我是刚暑假接到孩子出来深圳或暑假现在小孩还在我这里，然后我就有这个打算，心想如果我要争取抚养权的话，是不是我把小孩放到这边直接上学，我自己带会更好，因为我怕他来骚扰我，因为他威胁过我，他说如果你这样我光脚，不然很花销。我说你工方外貌各种闹，我又貌，到底什么都没有，他就是这个意思。我心想我如果硬强硬小孩来这边读书，我不。
他他知道到哪里，这样子会不会不好呢？比如说我们都双方请的律师去诉讼，这个事情呢，你不能说把孩子藏起来，不让他见，你得所有的证据，所有的录音，所有的电话通话，你都是好声好气的，你说你想见孩子随时都可以见啊，都是为孩子好啊，你不能留下任何把柄，你让他抓住把柄了，说你就是不让他见孩子明白，但是那他肯定会闹到这里来，他说那我现在要见孩子，如果我让他知道孩子跟我在哪里，他现在可以说无业，他天天跟你搞，我就不担心是这一点，因为我是要正常工作，以及孩子其实安排能正常安排好，但是我昨天有跟他好好沟通，我说小孩他也有提到说不想回家读书，要么让他尝试一学金，你们也父母休息一下，我说让我来尝试带，我说平时也是，你们总觉得你们带了辛苦了，我再好好跟他说，但是他的态度很坚决，就是你马上得给我送回来，然后现在还有一个问题点，我正处于现在工作的一个上升期嘛，我本来打算是说，如果他能好好说，小孩给你抚养没有问题，只要大家好好沟通，那我经想呢，在这四五年以内，我凭自己能力，我想着买个小房子，就是未来对孩子也好，各方面我是这样想的，但是他可能不这么认为，那我现在就很纠结，因为马上要开学了，要不要留在身边，如果我把他送回去，我这抚养权是很难争取到，因为小孩是已。
岁半不到2岁的时候，那时候送回去的嘛，他爷爷奶奶带，当时他爸妈就是为了不想他儿子去供房贷，他叫我出来供房贷，我说我在家带孩子，他家人不同意，就让我出去打工赚钱供房贷，不然这房子就没了，断供了就没了，可能就担心这样子，但是在这两年中，我也是喜欢学费跟奶粉衣服这些都是我支付的，你觉得这个事情啊，也要看看你背后有没有人支撑，如果说单凭你一个人又带孩子又工作的话，这也不现实，你娘家能给帮衬吗？能给助力吗？目前的话是这样的，我们家家人可能帮不了什么，但是我现在小孩4岁半，因为学校离我就很近，我工作地方也挨着不远，就小孩晚托我去了解了，晚托到6点半，我去接是没有问题的，就大家都住在一起，还是可以帮助的到，就所以我希望他一年级在这边读书，但是如果现在不去争取的话，以后一年级也是不可能来到这个城市读书，他们的观念就是把他放到农村里面赌去，因为他哥两个小孩就是这样子，如果对方最终的带孩子的模式是爸爸也不管，交给爷爷奶奶放到农村，那我建议你就是拼了命也得争孩子的抚养权了，命也得争，他想来闹，我又没有，我又没有偷人，我又没有违法，我又没有犯罪，我不怕你闹啊，你随便闹啊。所以我现在意思就是，如果说按照这样子，我小孩留在这边，现在就是自己。
鞋的这个事儿，就看你愿意为这个孩子付出到什么程度了，他说他光脚的不怕穿鞋的，老娘也是条光脚的不怕穿鞋。之前去年我也有很激烈的这种思想，但是我现在自己也想通了，我觉得他也并不值得我去做一些伤害自己的事情嘛，我也是这样觉得，但是现在我其实可能我80%大部分还是想说，因为两家挨太近了，我都在一个地方，想好好的两家人坐下来谈，但是我依然显然很难，我们过年跟我哥哥去他家，一家人好好坐下来谈，说的好好的，但是他就反悔了，就是很难去解决这个事情。姐妹啊，你知道在农村的小孩儿，农村的一个小女孩儿，她要经历哪些风险吗？如果是爷爷奶奶带她到农村长大的话，你知道农村的光棍率有多高吗？你知道一个小女孩在农村长大要经历多少风险吗？这个知道，反正我话只能点到这儿了，你自己再琢磨琢磨啊。还有最后一个问题就是如果我现在把小孩留在这里了，然后我请律师去诉讼，他有说过他跟我没什么好谈，他说他把他律师电话给我，让我的律师去跟他的律师谈，能否谈到一个方案，过年的我们的方案是这样的，因为我就跟他说卖房的钱我已经32万，我已经还掉，因为我自己也有债入，我说还掉20万就是10万块钱，我说那你这10万我们大家都不要，就留来用你小孩的教育啊，各方面我也每年都。
钱，这样子去持续点，然后他当然听的是觉得，哎，这方案挺好好的，还有一种就是我现在意思就是抚养权我要，但是就是说他们依然，如果还是想说小孩留在身边，留多一两年，等一年级的出来上学，我是否可以同意这样子罚你，如果孩子留在爷爷奶奶的身边，然后你的工作呢，又不在那个地方，那你几乎以后再也争不到孩子的抚养权了，就是他们的缓兵之计，好的，那意思就是我还是要坚持一点，现在我把小孩就在这边读书，然后请个律师去跟他谈，这个意思是的，每次的时间拉长，大概会要去到一年嘛，还很正常，行吧，那我还是按照这个思走吧，再看他们会不会好好说，好，先谢谢你，嗯，好，再见啊，拜拜多，请给我点关注。